tu fais quoi gros
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là pour le café et
bien regarder une nouvelle voiture de
BMW c'est la nouvelle x 51 est juste
là-bas vous allez voir électrique bien
évidemment il est bien WAV
électrification des véhicules on en
parle de plus en plus parce que toutes
les marques se met au vert se met à
l'électrique alors ça c'est pas le
déluge histoire pour BMW y en avait
d'autres face à une nouvelle bagnole
elle est vachement intéressant vachement
de points a montré au niveau de la
connectivité puis surtout la gueule
esthétique extrêmement race et on n'est
pas sûr SUV mets sur un SAV alors c'est
pas le SAV gens j'ai un problème
sport active véhicule regarder regarder
[Applaudissements]
viens mais ça c'est très très bien et
surtout vous dégage complètement l'écran
je vous expliquer toute la partie
collectivité écran parce que c'est
vraiment vous intéresser ici en fait
comme ça
et ça c'est très bien vu un
peu
je sais pas si c'est
pareil au niveau de la commande de
volume
sur les boutons
j'ai l'impression d'avoir des
commandes et je trouve un peu
mais je suis pas après ce que je vais
trouver ici au niveau de la commande
parce que même si
ça marche très très bien je trouve très
cool vous avez
donc ça ça marche
les bacs et on va retrouver au niveau du
dos donc ça ça marche bien écouté un peu
faussement capitonné voyez avec ce
côté-là il y a pas de capitaux c'est pas
vraiment l'esprit du capiton mais ça me
fait penser un petit peu par rapport
notamment parce que tu es un peu diable
alors le sien je trouve bien je trouve
bien l'inconvénient du siège baquet
c'est que lorsque vous êtes
ici c'est pas le
problème de
mon téléphone
Promax ça va bien me le recharger et ça
c'est cool moi j'ai pas démarrer un
petit bouton avec une boîte à gants on
peut mettre pas mal de choses dedans
BTS IG2 USB c'est également ici je vais
voir une petite clim indépendant siège
arrière siège chauffant avant bien
évidemment pour qu'on aille toute option
un grand toit panoramique complètement
dégagé on peut venir avec
[Musique]
la musique
centre
[Musique]
pour la bagnole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en terme de conduite comme tout
électrique d'accélération de dingue dans
ce qu'on a pu se mettre en ligne droite
et tu vas voir en fait attention on va
pas plus vite que la vie bien sûr mais
il faut faire très très bonne tenue de
route si j'accélère
[Rires]
super bien parce qu'en fait là je vais
voir la vue en trois dimensions ou
samedi cinéma route la sur l'écran
central je veux voir une ville de la
réalité augmentée lorsque je dois
tourner à droite à gauche c'est
vachement bien et après j'ai une autre
vie à droite avec une vue du dessus donc
là je peux pas me planter lorsqu'on lui
dis vraiment le choix c'est super bien
je vois en plus la vitesse à laquelle je
dois rouler là je suis sur une nationale
je suis limité à 80 km je peux à
prévenir modifier mon affichage choisir
la façon je veux que tu affiches moi
navigation en 2D
c'est très bien conçu et en plus c'est
vachement bien
c'est très
intelligente BMW
alarme pour 49 toutes les vitres il faut
savoir qu'il va faire 3 degrés on va lui
demander à mon ferme toutes les vitres
magnifique ton enfant derrière qui dit
21 papa est-ce que tu peux baisser la
vitre sur mon chéri je me dis bah non je
ne serai pas j'appuie sur le bouton la
fenêtre arrière droit de mettre de la
musique de
bien
évidemment
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui nous intéresse nous
adresser les écrans c'est la
connectivité
du logiciel de BMW
BMW
ouvre la navigation téléphone vous avez
les modes donc ça a l'air intéressant
sur votre profil de conduite sport
efficience efficience on va garder un
peu plus d'autonomie sport on va y aller
un peu plus fort mon copain c'est pas
mal de choses le petit massage
les lombaires et ça ça me plaît
énormément les différentes caméra il y a
une caméra dans l'habitacle également
juste qu'on peut venir récupérer ici
c'est imprévisible toutes vos
applications que vous pouvez avoir ici
ou Android auto une fois de plus de
stationnement il y a tout l'essentiel
d'une voiture et aussi tout un menu qui
est vachement bien pour tout ce qui va
être climatisation pour prévenir les
séparer ça c'est assez classique
automobile vos sièges chauffants le
volant chauffant on règle les différents
niveaux d'intensité tout l'expérience
logiciel est vachement bien conçu ça ça
me plaît énormément et c'est vraiment
très gros. Est-ce que vous savez où j'en
ai déjà parlé et je trouve que beaucoup
de marque essaie de venir un peu gratter
sur ce café aujourd'hui tu arrêtes la
référence tout ce qu'il veut être je
dirais parti software logiciel des fois
avec plus ou moins de réussite ils sont
vraiment bien réussi vient se faire très
facilement on aller dans 15 minutes pour
arriver à ce qu'on veut faire malgré
tout il y a 7 boutons qui sont assez
efficace pour le dégivrage rapide vous
avez sur votre sinon tout le reste est
inclus dans cette tablette devant vous
et à
votre vitesse de conduite vous l'avez
sur l'écran qui est sur la droite et
c'est pas extrêmement pratique et si
vous l'avez on a déjà c'est bien vous
l'avez également devant vous il y a
vraiment extrêmement pratique pour
navigation les écrans de tous les côtés
qui vous guide c'est bien c'est complet
c'est très compliqué cette expérience
logiciel ici se trouve hyper canon comme
il y a marqué ici par BMW le fais en
plus
de véhicule
par exemple
où est-ce que vous en êtes où
voir ce qui se passe et évidemment votre
clé où est-ce que vous avez dans votre
chargement si vous l'avez branchée sur
une borne Unity on va avoir 2 ans temps
et bien il vous dira où est-ce que vous
en êtes ça vous évite de venir voir tout
le temps sur la borne monde est la
charge pourrait boire un café peinard
BMW as vraiment un gros Focus au niveau
de la collectivité que ce soit au niveau
de son système embarqué que ce soit au
niveau du système applicatif ici
évidemment i OS Android nous c'est
vraiment ce qui vient de nous intéresser
la collectivité comment est-ce qu'on
arrive à gérer tout ça avant de partir
et bien vous êtes
vous lever déjeuner aller danser bien
avec ça vous avez tous et vous allez
tout ce qui se passe
[Musique]
Hôtel Le connectivité on va avoir une
piscine bien évidemment et puis de la 5G
dans la 5G il va arriver en 2022 encore
un petit peu de patience et pour la
déverrouiller on va utiliser son iPhone
et un iPhone pas n'importe lequel il
faudrait
111 à 13 ans comme ça avec
tout ce
qui se passe bien vous avez des
applications
j'avais pas directement sur la vitre
mais vous l'avez sur votre moniteur
centrale sur votre écran de 14 ans, vous
vous voyez où est-ce qu'il faut tourner
vous avez le panneau qui vient sur la
route vous donne la direction c'est très
pratique très immersif et là c'est
strictement impossible de venir ce qu'on
fait quand on conduit bien évidemment je
vous l'ai dit vous avez Apple carplay il
y a un truc qui est vachement sympa si
vous avez un petit bouton sur le volant
revenir appeler votre assistant
intelligent BMW bien lorsque vous êtes
connecté on Apple carplay vous appuyez
qui
va arriver également et
[Applaudissements]
tout
te suffit
et ben non on va la changer
on est débordé il y en a pas mal enfants
ça va continuer tout doucement ça arrive
on s'arrête sur une aire par exemple on
n'est pas très loin du monde
on a ce qu'il faut
vachement bien c'est que sur
l'application bien je vais voir à quel
moment je vais arriver jusqu'à 80 % et
parce qu'en fait les batteries ce qu'il
faut savoir charger plus vite que la
vitesse de charge va vraiment
remets la batterie ça sert à rien de
monter au lieu de 80 % ça va vous coûter
cher en temps passé parce que vous allez
récupérer
voilà vous savez tous quasiment tout sur
la 6 50 j'ai du mal des fois je mets 50
ans un peu les mots on a fait le tour de
toute la partie de connectivité si vous
voulez avoir beaucoup d'informations sur
le véhicule sur la puissance performance
tout ce qui va être autonomie et
compagnie je vous invite aller voir les
chaînes spécialisées qui vont en
automobile si c'est une chaîne donc on
parle de tes qu'on parle de connexion
avec vos smartphone qui coûte 103500 €
et que j'aime bien sûr c'est vachement
bien exprès de conduite c'est hyper
agréable même si c'est un SAV on est
dans l'idée du SUV c'est une quatre
roues motrices ça fonctionne bien c'est
très agréable on peut passer un peu
partout avec merci bien W et je suis
désolé je voulais pas mais quand on aime
on ne compte pas on va continuer à
parler de l'automobile un autre véhicule
de d'un WC connecter abonnez-vous si
vous avez des questions interrogation
sur la connectivité de tout marquer en
commentaire se trouve très rapidement
bisous Ciao
[Musique]